hey guys
we just watched jungle cruise for some
reason or
recording on the phone i just realized
that you could just record for the
actual camera
you know it's a lot more off the cuff it
it creates a you know a more
familial vibe slightly different vibe
for some reason a little bit
people can tell if you haven't seen the
chat for jungle cruise um
basically rachel weiss and her brother
hire brennan fraser
as they look for oh wait no no no no no
dude wait a minute that's a totally
different
movie but if you guys have seen the
mummy and kind of like pirates of the
caribbean
you might like this one it's based on
the disneyland theme park ride
where a small riverboat takes a group of
travelers
through a jungle filled with dangerous
animals and reptiles
but with a a supernatural element
isn't that nice totally whipped that up
did not casually read that off imdb
just now but john hey what did you think
of the jamie colette
sarah directed jungle cruise uh
i i'm a little torn i'm very torn on it
there are parts of this movie that i
really
did enjoy that i do think are a lot of
fun and that are within a film tradition
that i
am happy to see still alive and well to
a degree however i think
that there is a certain amount that is
kind of choked by
uh the the the editing and the just sort
of breakneck pace that the movie
commits to and never deviates from true
but what did you think gregory
well john uh i'll tell you what i liked
okay let's start with and tell you what
i like let's have a positive
i thought dwayne johnson was the best
part of this movie
very enjoyable very enjoyable he's got a
lot of dad jokes
i kind of wish for promotion maybe they
did and i just didn't hear about it i
kind of hoped for promotional purposes
that they just let him be the skipper at
disneyland for like
a random tour ride i would love at least
when they do have the scene in there
where they are aping off the ride itself
with the skipper taking american
tourists on on a cruise through the john
i don't know if they're all american but
you know they're taking him through a
cruise
a little tour boat he's a con artist i i
really like that scene a lot and he's
got some hilarious dad jokes and he has
a lot of charisma
it's a well-produced disney movie in the
sense of production design like i love
the costumes i think the makeup is
really good
and it harkens well to adventureland you
know those like
just surrounding areas of the river
there were times where like straight up
look like disneyland
yeah it's just like look like disneyland
for the most part
liked emily blunt's character and i
think her and dwayne johnson do
ultimately have good chemistry together
i like the brother yeah who is the
brother there's a big deal about him
this
this was coming out ages ago about it it
was a gay character and it was like
disney's finally happy like
oh goodness it's like a scary character
anytime she does anything slightly
progressive in this way yeah they're
like
freaking bravo disney let's get
everybody i sure had us on them you guys
are champions
we acknowledge gayness you're real
heroes
okay cheetah or leopard jaguar jaguar
i think it was a jaguar jaguar
characters
but in all honesty i i honestly um
i kept trying to do the thing of
okay it's it's for families right it's
designed for families it's for kids
all right this is the target demographic
it's supposed to be that but then my
mind would go to like
but there's really good versions
of that a lot of time you know you
criticize a movie like this
and then yeah yes yeah those people come
in and go who do you think this movie's
for
it's supposed to be for family and kids
and his dad it's passable all right
okay fine sure i'm not a family and i'm
not a kid
so but i i've seen movies based for that
demographic that i personally preferred
and this is just my
opinion on the matter and my opinion on
it
is that i thought this movie was
actually very annoying um
i i thought that the edit like you
brought the editing how much time i'm
like this movie is so
loud and so bombastic and it just
doesn't stop being edited like the
editing just
doesn't like ever let me down and it's
it's so
noisy who really struck me halfway
through is like how come there's so much
happening yet i don't feel like it's a
sense of adventure it's clearly aping
off of certain things of the mummy but
it's also trying to
be kind of tonally or spiritually
more like the first pirates of the
caribbean movie i think with a sense of
adventure in peril and then the random
supernatural
angle and that's a movie design for
families and i think that's one of the
best blockbusters of all time
yeah absolutely that is doing a lot of
the same things this movie is trying to
do but letting them breathe and be
quirky and develop over time instead of
just hurtling
towards you know a mcguffin that you
know isn't even a part of the actual
source
and you have like the main villain in
here like there's a lot of random
villains in here and i'm like who's the
main okay i guess
i guess the main one is jesse plemmons
who uh does a german accent in here that
i i quite enjoyed
yeah i enjoyed his german accent
ultimately
in this movie itself i ended up kind of
just finding everyone
frustrating for some reason like even
though i love emily blunt i think she's
like arguably the best
actress around definitely one of the
best like actors in
total around right now and dwayne
johnson as weird as it is to see this
guy in the 19th century my friend tony
was like
man that guy like that in the 1920s
you'd be like put him in the
yes circus be the strong man he'd be the
giant but i will say
like my favorite part of it was his
character it was the it was the one
thing that i was like i am really on
board for at least this character
then they it's a major spoiler if i
say what it is but if you've seen the
movie
and there's this thing that they
introduce about his character
halfway through it just destroyed my
experience of the character from that
from there on i was like i do not like
this
it completely eliminates almost
everything that i
liked about the archetype of this guy
yeah
i appreciate them trying to do something
different but i also felt
i got so cynical about it like are you
doing this just because it's the rock
yeah absolutely and i mean this is gonna
be classic greg and john where it's like
i don't hate that thing you're talking
about but it was a moment when i was
watching it where i
did lose a little bit of investment and
also i think it was one of those moments
where i could tell like oh yeah this is
the pivot point for
all watchers of this movie where you're
either going to be
that much more with it or really not
with it
from there and i think yeah i mean
ultimately the energy of the movie does
become
something that you really you really
have to be like well rested and
and just have eaten to watch this video
so that you're like completely alert
because
yeah i mean it does become just a lot
thrown
at you and it moves at such a breakneck
pace and yeah you do have all these
characters to the point that
i imagine it would be pretty easy to
lose track of the plot
at a certain point because it's hitting
you with a lot of
information but also it's doing it in a
very sort of
fast and uh breathless sort of way and i
was kind of surprised
that there was like close to i i can't
recall the scene with a real animal
yeah there was a lot a lot a lot a lot
of cg and i thought there was some
terrible cgi i thought i thought like
it's it's strange like i like the
production design i like the stages i
like
the locations they shot on i like the
costumes i like the makeup but the cgi
on some of these unlike the animals and
and then some of the more supernatural
villains yeah was like davey jones from
10 years ago looks better
than this you know i'm like now one of
them comes close to matching that
yeah it really does feel like there is a
broad array of
levels of quality when it comes to the
effects across the movie yeah certain
things look as good as you might expect
and then other things
don't and there's not really quite an
economy of like oh yeah i can see
why they chose to favor this one thing
over another so like it does
kind of add perhaps to a garishness
of the movie overall and it does
probably undercut a lot of the fantasy
because like for me this experience like
i did get to watch it in a family
environment
to at least a certain degree like adult
family but you know with
my family who i would go to a family
movie with and then we met up
and then we talked about it yeah yeah
yeah and so like that experience like we
all had a good time and i would imagine
that maybe on a big screen it would be
more fun um
i can also imagine it being that much
more harsh is the problem there are
certain elements of the movie that i
really was having
fun with but then when it stopped being
appropriate for the pace they're not
just cutting a lot
they're also changing shots all the time
and so there's like a lot of really cool
and
imaginative camera work hidden in this
pace of editing that is like really
almost algorithmic in how sort of just
mathematical it feels and i really got
started to feel like this was a much
longer movie that had been cut
down because even if you look at a lot
of the dialogue then this is something
you pointed out and something else and i
started to notice here was like oh so
much of this dialogue
is played over uh inserts and reaction
shots and you'll see a few lines of
somebody saying what they're actually
doing in the scene
really started to feel like they had a
movie that breathed and then they cut it
down to just the plot points
yeah and so yeah you get the actors work
which is still pretty good across the
board but you also don't get any
dynamics to help prime you from one
character to the next yeah it's really
easy to get lost in the chaos of the
movie itself
yeah i didn't particularly find it
charming or exciting even though there
was a lot going on
dylan johnson is still my favorite part
of the movie i wasn't in love with the
chemistry i
i bet if i went to rotten tomatoes or be
a lot of people being like
thank god emily blunt and dwayne johnson
yeah because honestly
i'll be i'll be honest with you like
there were parts about emily blunt's
character
early on that i thought were kind of
frustrating i didn't love the writing
of a lot of characters especially with
some of that
and i hate to say like stuff like this
but you know like the way they handle
the pat on the back like oh look at us
being progressive
could have been a lot more uh human and
smooth even with the whole thing of like
yeah i get what you're doing you have a
lead female character plucked in the
1920s where
especially then women were very much
oppressed yeah you're doing your african
queen
catholic they are freaking it and i know
it's for families and kids
but they are they are hitting you over
the head with it i'm not one to be like
freaking woke culture and disney pushing
your agenda whenever
i feel that way i don't feel like
they're actually pushing their real
agendas i feel like they're
placating to something that they think
people will love
that's kind of what i felt like with her
character i was like
damn you know i i love emily blunt but
it just it was so it just wouldn't stop
even one of her nicknames his pants
got after a while like this is not
charming this reoccurring bit
about how she's wearing pants and then
maybe nickname her pants and
and i was just like dude it's not funny
it wasn't that funny the first time you
knew this is this movie he thinks it's
so
funny to call it it just kept going and
everything that's like becomes like the
charming nickname that dwayne johnson
gives her
and by then i was like all right if
you're gonna nickname her that fine but
man they were like playing for laughs
this is such a stupid joke
cut it out i really thought that this
would at least be a very enjoyable movie
yeah and normally in a movie like this i
feel like i'm the guy telling you guys
like line it up
nobody wants to be grumpy about the
jungle cruise yeah unless it's cynical
and it i don't know it
feels cynical it's not it's just
honestly the word that comes to mind is
it's annoying that's that's the word i
associated with this is like i just i
just found myself annoyed when i was
watching it
yeah it's like you really took the ride
part way
too literally and it's funny because you
know like the best part is when he's
just doing the right yeah
he's just literally doing what you can
get at disneyland
and if yeah had a little bit more of
that quaint
charm infused with it instead of trying
to rock it
off into a crazy you know like ages old
you know
quest for an ancient macguffin with
magic power look
pirates of the caribbean ride lends
itself to that
to a certain extent pirates sailing the
sea you know
and there are inherent ghost stories in
there and the thing is like there is
inherent
versions of that in what the jungle
cruise is and what the pirates movies
managed to do with they chose the kind
of right level
to jump to in the right aesthetic to
match that
and i feel like there is that for this
and it's kind of what they went for but
not
in terms of the style they they went
like pirates
four or five level production value type
with you know something that should have
felt a little bit more like the early
pirates movies that are produced like
the actual epics they want to be
all right well you're like a 5 out of 10
just for
shit's sake i'll give it a 6 point
as you guys think of jungle cruise
all right bye